well I could play this tournament starts
in three minutes think I'll do that I'm
looking I'm looking like a snack today
what does that even mean I mean I have
snacks next to me Oh
Attila - so a little thanks for the rain
I appreciate that I'm getting a
challenge from someone called company
with a K do I play this guy or do I play
the tournament
I'll let the chat decide you want to see
blitz where I'll probably play a strong
player in the first game or do you want
to see me play someone in a longer game
where I would have better chances to win
if no one says anything that I have to
make a decision which isn't the most
preferable cuz I'm indecisive okay Gio
if it says tournament what does that
name the real donkey pride says
challenge challenge trim it Wow so it's
tied to two - oh he says win and then
play in the tournament wow it's so split
tournament longer time control okay so I
think the best compromise is to play
this guy first and then join the
tournaments that way I dodge the
stronger players in the first round
I thought they accepted the challenge
which just happened what
what just happened is it I just closed
all my tabs I swear I accepted the
challenge oh I have a game in progress
why does that happen sometimes
we're like starts a game but it doesn't
load on the page
ok so let's play don't just play normal
I'm not gonna play any crazy gambits
unless people want to see crazy habits
but you've already made enough decisions
for me so let's play knight c6 over a
little bit then we have some position
which okay he's he's probably a Spanish
player
I said no crazy gambit son I was
considering playing f5 let's just play a
six I'll treat this as if I were in the
tournament I'll just play what I have in
my tournament preparation right c3 c3
I've actually never seen this before
after Bishop a4 the first thing that
comes to mind is winning upon b5 Bishop
b3 b4 and then the knight moves away and
I win he for that might be too much but
what happens Mike d5 wait I'm playing
the super blitz arena - oh no I'm
playing two games at once I'm playing
Farmville and I'm playing the sky why is
this happening before no I guess I have
to focus on my farmville game first I
didn't even know you can do that like it
starts tombs at once okay well he's
thinking that's good so accidental Simon
farmville is very strong it's like
speech us I think maybe can i play h5
here looks like I move but then light c3
that's Knight g3 maybe I can play Bishop
g4 provoke f3 put the bishop on h3
there's AB g2 ideas White House Center
clones well I have two bishops and I
have to open half open Center files he's
still thinking that's great
maybe he's watching and he feels bad for
me I accidentally started to use little
Castle queenside and put the bishop on
d4 and get just get ready to complete
development if a3 I don't know III
Bishop a5 I guess Bishop can always come
back let's take and play f6 undermining
the bishop
but the bishop back where it belongs my
bishops will probably stand here and
here and my Rick's will stands here and
here his Knights kind of annoying
so let's attack it if before Bishop d6
well he's still Bishop b6 it's
interesting kind of setup like we're
both relatively solid I don't really
want to play Bishop a7 but maybe I have
to yeah cuz I don't want him to trade
off the the night he might play C c4 c5
that could be terrifying ABC for b5 well
he's allowing b5 that's a fork and
that's my my stream title is fork night
in this case I'm working a queen and a
knight let's do it
so he got some comp but hopefully not
too much I mean he has pawns ok rugby
it's coming
how many pawns does white have I don't
want to count his 7 I have four so three
pawns for a bishop well it's still
double-edged this guy move yet 95 let's
take up on
I really shouldn't focus on hacking too
much it's from toilet noggin welcome
back to what noggin I don't know what to
do
although the bishop trade because I have
to maybe see six or I don't know look
what the Queen here won't play c6 or c5
at some point
well it looks bad let's put the Queen
here change the plans attacking a3 may
be preparing c5 even can people here the
airplane not sure how a lot of it is
people definitely hear the airplane
rights as I'm next to in airports what
am I doing with my queen it's now I have
some plan of f5 there and try and
provoke a trade Oh Queen a for coming
that's not good okay well get into it
let's put their work on b6 he's gonna
play c4 maybe this looks very very scary
my bishops just dead but my rooks are
kind of alive
the Queen here a3s of targets
I'd rather be white preventing me 5 or
at least trying to prevent any 5 maybe
my King should just run like the wind or
like Forrest Gump I'm threatening to
take on c6 maybe he's thinking which is
good takes let's do it don't see
anything wrong with it maybe he'll take
Wow so now Queen and Bishop ooh I can
take here tactics his pawns have fallen
like that one Empire in history okay
let's put the Queen here and his king is
more exposing my king put the King here
unpin the bishop and then friending this
mmm I attack oh I have a trick Queen
takes b5 and Bishop descends a threat -
there should be sevens and monster
threats how's my time doing it's okay 57
check maybe here attack from the rear
should be some mating that somewhere
it's better be neat somehow there we go
okay that was satisfying new game or
next game old game current game for
those who just joined I messed up and I
I started a game while still in a
tournament
so it started both games at once
thankfully this is this is a 10 minute
game another game was a 3 minute game so
I've lost about what 6 minutes just
playing another game so this this guy
essentially has time loads but I won a
pawn because I was greedy toward the
noggin with 190 bits is there a
significance to that number or you're
just trying to confuse me and distract
me from the game also for any subs in
the chat including toilet noggin there
is now a toilet noggin emote which I was
very proud of my best attempt to
visualise toilet noggin and not too many
pixels I'm very happy to get rid of this
efficient $15 what does that even say
it's trying to eat it hey I just want to
say thanks all lessons love the once
English this club hopefully you make a
youtube series called openings I'm new
to chess I didn't catch the last parts
but thanks for the comment and the
donation I really appreciate that I'll
have to go back and see what like the
last few words were nice a video series
on openings yeah I'm kind of trying to
do that I need something more organized
though as recently actually I did a few
like lesson videos recently on the
Budapest well a lot has been just
playing games and explaining the
openings this is an opening I'll have to
look up
four nights with like a six and Bishop
a4
there should be three is a good move I
could take I think I'll take in White's
getting some F file and some Center I
just want to keep things simple and be
solid yeah Patrick J MT you should start
a twitch channel this is live stream
math you'll just dominate the markets
and the confidence is there even
competition for live streaming math like
do a Q&A with like homework help I'll be
so great
you'll get all the donations from like
the college students and high school
kids do you now have another Blitz game
to play you are also in that tournament
do you want to play me probably I don't
know what I'll do after this I'll let
the chat decide if I should play the
tournament to just accept challenges
let's take on pissant cuz it's always
cool and he won Connect four I heard
recently that Connect four has seven
files and not eight which I was very
suspicious of but maybe it's true it's
been a while since I played Connect four
oh my opponent said something in the
chat he said the game is casual a win
the tournament game
well that was mission accomplished it's
now all the focus is on this game odd
number and ok so there is 7 files is
connect for a forced win I think it is
right so listening to some podcasts
other day its Freakonomics and said how
the the episode was called how to win it
games
I was really interesting like about game
theory and strategy so it is a forced
win and checkers is a forced draw as far
as I know let's play out 5 very thematic
move if he lets me I would love to
playoff for if I get a foreign that I
can start attacking on the licking side
mmm each six looks attractive
I don't think 95 was that useful because
now the night is getting kicked
if you like I would like to fork some
nights continue the theme of the stream
and Toyota noggin with gifting subs Wow
gifting subs to so many people gigawatts
TV and Miam and Casey chess is my love
and disco Stu welcome to the new subs
we're gonna get to see a lot of this
bird get enjoy the bird while it lasts
thanks toilet noggin let's play a f4
just have a massive punching and then
maybe maybe I'll just continue storming
what computer do I use the stream I
would show you if I have a mirror but I
don't have a mirror it's um what is it a
28:15 math book fro it gets the job done
easy to travel with
and these lights look very shaky I want
to play h5 for the 9f2
let's just do this I want to transfer
the Queen to g6 and maybe I'll play g5
first over that would hang h6 so maybe
I'll play Queen h6 first the goal is
still tough work some nights maybe Queen
here is technically forking nights this
will probably turn into the sometime
scramble I think we're both playing very
slowly Fork Knights is better than 40
nights with Knight spelled two different
ways I could have taken the night but I
didn't want to trade off my amazing
bishop like even though my bishops
undeveloped it's happy along this
diagonal it's very common in like Kings
Indian structure to you just give me a
knight for a pawn that's nice because my
King is very safe and I'm actually very
happy to open the G file golf could
probably go for King age 7 and then
create some battery you owe me in the
chats
welcome back humor me lots of mods in
the chat as you nation chess as well I
don't know what he means by join the
dark side Oh probably convincing Patrick
to start streaming
Wow so he's inviting Bishop g4 which
looks nice
let's do it it's more material he has a
smooth rock g3 which might be the best
move because I would take he takes but
okay for now I think I'll leave all the
tension play kini cheats and the rook is
still pinned there's a rule in chess you
should not take a pin to peace if you
don't have to or if it doesn't meet
anything like that crushing sometimes a
pin is mightier than the sword so the
goal is to whoa more suggs
where Logan has gifted 75 subs total to
the channel over I think that's like
over our lifetime do I have to read off
all these memes I'll try and read off
all the names I have to focus on playing
moves - oh he unpinned himself but it's
okay because if the rook moves I can
take the knight and the G pawn is pinned
I feel like I feel like toilet just
wants to see the bird pop up as many
times as possible
I thought Patrick jammed he wasn't on
now you are
why does I thought toilet logon was an
MVP or VIP ah I think I tried to make
him a VIP like some earlier stream well
I typed MVP ants on a VIP there you go
unable to add VIP what can there only be
one VIP this looks nice I have pressure
against G two pieces are doing work
actually there's a move for a white
which looks complicated rook h4 oh you
can't be both I'm VIP and Ahmad ah so
that explains both the situation for
Patrick and Twitter nugget but what's
the benefit to VIP Oh is there any
benefit it's just the box next to your
name best tips to improve middle game
studying games from strong players find
any book that has like a collection of
annotated games and play through the
games and read the annotations pick up a
lot of middle game ideas okay so time is
good enough g8 looks nice now I didn't
read off the subs too distracted silver
a pork watching from Italy mice never
been to Italy but it's on my bucket list
it's pretty high on my bucket list too
I'll be within the top 5 countries that
I haven't been to so I don't know if
I'll win by meat or flagging him
probably by flagging him but I'll try
and meet as quickly as possible
yeah Knight f3 it would be the quickest
Auggie Flags I wanted to suck I wanted
him to at least take my queen okay well
good game company bad mood Kanye yeah
let's take a quick look at the opening
just cuz I'm curious not sure if I was
overly greedy Tori noggin with more sons
was what yes there's no there's there is
an excuse not to read off all the names
because I still didn't read off the
names from before her what's going on
what okay brace yourself for more bird
something's that total twenty five plus
five plus ten can't count that high
thanks toilet noggin okay that's for the
opening just briefly Knight c3 like
almost a novelty maybe yeah enjoy the
new emails to all the new subs
oh he gifted 25 because now it's a
hundred total like over our lifetime
that's nice Oh master is let's see
Knight c3 has been played before
oh wow some top tier games obstructed by
the bird so what is the point after it'd
be fine there should be three oh no one
plays b4 so maybe before was a blunder
but why
Celie chess so if you're just trying to
distract me oh man Sebulba with the
steak steak steak emotes nice
okay so before I had the feeling this
probably wasn't right ah
Queenie too simple move so maybe white
just wins back up on and gets a good
enough position might see five though
takes takes takes takes ninety six
defending everything let's cheat and
Hugh stockfish 95 maybe this is a reason
I didn't see that there my g5 is plus
one point six what a move
counter-attacking if d OD five is
basically the only move but because the
night is on c3 it's different than like
the traditional fried liver Wow yeah so
my opponent
despite being rated 1274 he had a chance
to just be crushing me if you played
Knight g5 interesting well I've only
played two names so far accidental Simon
I'll probably put this on youtube I
don't know what i'll call it probably
just accidental Simon